oh it is dark oh my god
and you said this is some type of weird
kinky thing that white people are doing
we're just kind of jamming whatever
comes our way in our mouth I don't know
where to put my office this is super
creepy I'm hungry so just better not be
horrible character clear oh it's like a
nut no it feels like it's chocolate he's
all not a cashew
we're like the daredevil right now we're
blind but our tastes our sense of smell
and taste is just like heightened to a
superhero agree oh I ate it already your
eat no I hate it oh why me oh it's wet
oh oh
watermelon mango thing is a piece I
think you're close it's like a apricot
cantaloupe does it cantaloupe honeydew
melon Wow so when you can't see I didn't
want to touch it anymore whatever this
is it tastes much better in the dark
Hey Kiwi Kiwi high-five
that's right I'll tell you right now I
hate it oh no I don't want to swallow
this believe all oh yeah oh oh oh it's
hot my tongue hurts this is ginger it's
ginger
oh my [ __ ] definitely dinner ah can I
get a tissue
this is shabby nothing there's a new one
okay yeah it tastes bizarre right whoa
I think it might be hearts of palm Elle
is that I have no idea it smells like
corn doesn't it not at all no take that
guys this is madness that was a bit
that's pretty normal is it OOP someone
beat it's like with your grandmother
Kees is usually here take some beats and
like know what China coordinate what mmm
go nice scrubbing boom please my finger
was in your mouth of a good day
come here manchego cheese I'm not a
foodie I don't know any of these turns
whoa
that is like a hockey bag my god it
tastes better when you're being fed
cheese this is a weird Freudian thing
that happened right there
something about eating in the dark Adams
is really kind of sexy yeah I'm into
danger yes very good like I usually be
scared of the texture of food try it
because I actually really like this I
love like heightened senses and this was
just the epitome of it okay three two no
here we will just start right here okay
there - OH